Helen
um devastated that you are gone like
during that Premiere episode I was like
oh my gosh I love Helen so much I love
her energy I love her puzzle solving
skills I just love her energy and
everything about you so I'm so sad to
have seen you go and you know after
watching it how are you feeling now the
dust is kind of settled
yeah thank you for saying that it's
really kind of you
um it's definitely super emotional I'm
devastated as well this happened nine
months ago I'm still devastated I
watched it yesterday and it was
definitely an emotional
um experience and and I think you kind
of see everything and hear everything in
my voice and face in that like little
confessional after the tribal um it was
just like
could not comprehend body was like in
Bear like paralysis just trying to like
process everything that was happening
yeah and speaking of that confessional
something that really stuck out to me
that I wanted to ask you about was you
know you felt like you after that all
happened The Blind Side you felt like
you were second guessing every
connection that you made was there
someone in particular that you were like
oh my gosh I feel so betrayed by them or
was it just everyone on the new tribe
yeah I think I think I don't see it as a
betrayal because this is you know the
first Tribal Council we went into we
know the game and we know everyone's a
player right so I give big kudos to the
the move I respected immensely I think
for me I just
um felt very much like I had misjudged a
lot of things and I pride myself on
someone as someone who is you know
self-aware and like understands where I
stand with people so I just felt like it
was a huge surprise to me that Carson
had slept
um I knew Sarah didn't have a vote but
she didn't have because she didn't have
a vote there was like no way for me to
judge whether she was on my side or not
either so I think coming out of that I
was just like oh man like was it just
like four versus one everyone was
against me and that was a tough pill to
swallow
oh I can only imagine and like speaking
of Carson like were you surprised to see
that like he was playing both sides
um yes I think it was a risk that we
were kind of aware of because
um between myself and Sarah versus jam
and Carolyn Carson was definitely the
person that was best positioned to make
inroads if we wanted to get one of them
over on our side so we did lean on him
to kind of like talk to them he had
really good relationships with them he
had put himself in a really really good
play socially
um so we knew that he was talking to
them he was giving us information that
they were telling him like oh you know
Carolyn said that you said this and she
doesn't believe it and stuff like that
so we were aware that he was talking to
both parties I think I just thought that
he was in our camp and he wasn't
gotcha that's so interesting I love
hearing that different perspective and
everything as a Survivor fan so
fascinating to me to hear all the ins
and outs of everything
um I have to talk about obviously the
bird cage and everything that happened
with that like when you guys all saw you
know that it had been tampered with was
there like what was going through your
mind because from what we saw everyone
had a different idea of like who got the
whatever was in that right yeah and um I
think in the show it looks like it's a
lot closer of a timeline from when
Carolyn takes everything and puts it
back until when we discover the birdcage
I think it was probably over like a
night I remember waking up and be like
oh this looks different than it did
yesterday so it was a much longer
timeline and because of that there was a
lot of possible deniability of like any
one of us could have been there and done
this
um yeah for me I obviously knew I didn't
have it I didn't suspect Carolyn that
much because she was so unfiltered out
there that I was like I feel like she
would tip us off somehow like if she
found it and it'd be really hard for her
to hide it and she obviously did like a
much better job than um I expected and
so in my head I was like it must be
Carson Sarah or Jam I'm hoping it's
Carson or Sarah because you know then
hopefully they're using it for the good
of our alliance and not to get me out
but I didn't know who it was to be
honest oh really that's so interesting
because it seemed like everyone had
different suspects reading body language
and all that kind of stuff like it just
seemed kind of like scramble when all of
you guys were looking at it yeah was it
like that and it causes so much paranoia
right like the bird cage for us like
because we knew that something had been
tampered with the whole afternoon you're
just thinking like okay not only is
there now a shot in the dark that you
have to factor into all of your decision
making that there wasn't in the um old
era of the game but there's probably
going to be an idol there so how do you
Shore up every single plan that you're
making so that if plan a doesn't work
plan b or c can come into play and I
think all of that planning and trying to
make sure everything was perfect
probably played a part in my removal
from the game
well I feel like there were so many
factors and it's probably hard to narrow
down to just like one moment that you
know sent you home but I do have to ask
as you mentioned the shot in the dark is
like a new way of Survivor did you
consider playing it or did you go into
tribal like you know kind of confident
I didn't consider playing it um I think
for a number of reasons I knew that
Sarah had already lost her vote so I
knew that like the numbers we were
playing with were already pretty slim
margin like if we could get jammed then
we would get the numbers without me like
a lot of things kind of don't work with
our plan
um and I think in the first vote I was
kind of hoping to establish trust with
the people I was working with and I
think that that is a big thing where
like if you're not doing what you're
saying you're doing then that can really
bite you in the butt and like maybe they
don't want to work with me down the line
so
um not a big consideration probably
should have been but no
was there anything at tribal that anyone
said that kind of like tipped you off
and made you feel like oh gosh like you
know this isn't I might be going home
like there was a moment where you guys
were all talking about tribe strength
and like what that means to you and
everyone kind of had you know different
answers was there anything that went off
in tribal that you were like oh this
might not be good for me
I think tribal so tribal for us was a
little shorter than I expected I think
it was maybe like an hour under an hour
so we didn't cover too much stuff and I
think for myself I was trying to
um keep myself calm because I think that
there are a lot of things that tribal
that can spook you and I I probably
defaulted to like too much of like the
the opposite side of paranoia where I
wasn't paranoid enough so really the
first like hint that I got that it was
not gonna go my way is literally when
Jeff like shows the Carolyn bow and I
see it in my handwriting and I'm like oh
no it's definitely me
yeah oh I can only imagine like what
goes through your head as those votes
are being read like it it's crazy to
watch so I can't imagine what it's like
to actually go through
um but lastly I just want to ask you I
know it didn't exactly play out how you
wanted it to your time on Survivor
especially as a Survivor fan but what
would you say were like your biggest
takeaways from your time in the game
oh my biggest takeaways
um
this game like this game is is really
crazy like I I think it's just like
today's game so many people come to this
game and are huge huge fans and they
know how to play and
my takeaway is I should have been way
more paranoid like I should have known
that people had come to play and um
nothing comes easy on Survivor and what
feels like an easy vote is never gonna
be an easy vote so I think that was the
biggest thing for me
um I think another takeaway is just that
like
even though our tribe had so many
tribulations in the first few days I do
think that our tribe like did bond in a
way that like
carried us you know farther than you
would expect for such a small tribe like
I I remember we were practicing like
rowing the boat in sync ahead of the
first immunity challenge because we were
like okay we don't have the muscles that
the other tribes do but like if we're in
sync if we're together we can make it
happen and you see us like screaming
like one two scoop like during that
challenge and we were able to keep up
with all of the tribes with their big
firefighters and NFL players so I was
proud of that
uh well I love that and that's very like
Bruce when I spoke to him last week he I
talked about that Bond you had like he
had with you guys for only being there
for a day so with even just from that it
was very clear that you guys were very
close so I mean I'm sad that you're gone
maybe like we can manifest a return of
Helen maybe one day like I would like to
see Jamie bing bing bing like yeah it's
gonna happen it's gonna happen we're
gonna manifest we're gonna make it
happen but um thank you so much for your
time today was lovely chatting with you
and I'm looking forward to the rest of
the season and I hope you're gonna watch
as well
um oh absolutely so much